investigative reporting by a group of
student journalists forced their new
principal to resign
amy robertson was hired last month to
lead a kansas high school when the
students set out to write a story about
her they found some inconsistencies in
Robertson's credentials Omar Villafranca
is in Pittsburg Kansas inside the High
School where the new principal quit
before her first day good morning
there is a job opening at Pittsburgh
High School because of what happened in
this small newsroom student journalists
started asking questions about Amy
Robertson and they found things out that
the school board did not they found out
that the incoming principal's advanced
degrees were not worth the paper they
were printed on no one really knew who
she was and so we wanted to shed some
light on that when students at Pittsburg
high school started asking routine
questions about incoming principal Amy
Robertson they didn't like what they
heard looking to her background we
noticed several discrepancies and
several red flags
that's when 17 year old journalists Gina
Matthew and Connor Balthasar went to
work in last week's issue of the booster
redux students detailed a march 16th
conference call where Robertson gave
them incomplete answers conflicting
dates and inconsistencies Robertson who
was interviewed for the position from
her home in Dubai said she earned a
masters and a doctorate from courtland's
University online but that she also
occasionally traveled to the on-site
campus in Stockton California
Portland's University was unaccredited
and it also had discrepancies within
being a diploma mill or degree mill this
website for courtland's university shows
a commencement ceremony but that photo
is actually from Wake Forest University
a spokesman for the US Department of
Education tells CBS News the department
does not have a record of Courland
University we had two committees of
people who interviewed her
superintendent Destry Brown says he's
proud of the students and says
Robertson's 93 thousand dollar a year
hiring was doomed without the proper
documentation they would mail get a
license in Kansas so
eventually the I'll just say the
chickens would have come to roost most
people don't want their taxpayer dollars
going towards the salary if somebody
that lied in looking out for their
school community
these students also learned the value in
shoe-leather reporting we understand our
roles and that is to present the truth
Robertson's undergraduate degree is also
in question a spokesperson for the
University of Tulsa tells CBS News
Robertson did attend but did not
graduate we reached out to Robertson on
multiple platforms and did not receive a
comment back from her Nora all right
Omar thank you now that's what you call
real news and getting a question and
they followed it through and with
significant result and mrs. Robertson is
going Thank You kids so good you're so
good at your job and you know it's
interesting but I think it's great
brothers at the Boston Globe spotlight
unit reached out to these these students
to say Bravo well done yeah but it's one
more time in which you say go to look at
the fundamentals yeah